um I mean you have I would say pretty
similar to some rap music what are your
favorite albums this year
of course KD three yeah um I really [ __ ]
with the 21 Savage Drake album her loss
I agree stupid Doper than I than I
expected my top ten for sure yeah
um Kendrick of course yeah
your boy Freddie Gibbs is definitely in
the top five Triple S
um you know you know which one I really
like that I haven't heard people talk
about Montega
French French
that was one album that I was listening
to a lot like no I mean like that shit's
definitely French albums
honestly those would probably be my top
five but I love the Joey Badass one of
course Pusha T
Usha T is always into how many years the
French album is definitely slept on
Harry Potter I mean Harry Fraud and 38
Specialists put out a crazy project okay
I haven't heard that one yet LeBron's
been posting it like every other [ __ ]
day really that's what's up yeah I [ __ ]
with 38 Special heavy like as a fan
you are right though that French album
is hard and nobody's really [ __ ] get
like I feel like it's underrated bro
super underrated like French go hard on
them hairy frog bees bro that's French
that's his sound yeah that's what I
think for sure
the [ __ ] hairy frog beats yeah like
he's a pop star and you know starts
[ __ ] Kardashians shout out to French
man legendary Hit List That French
Montana he's got a roster that's what
they say who he's like top five best
rosters in hip-hop Let's see we go
French who else is amazing Drake
obviously Drake's got a roster
Travis Nick Cannon Nick Cannon's got it
you know who Loki has a crazy roster I
don't know if it's Loki Scott Storage
yeah no my brother he's Loki and high
key and high key he's told me because
yeah Scott Storage will tell you stories
about girls he used to [ __ ]
and you'll be like oh you hit it first
yeah cause that [ __ ] was in the 2000s
Scott Storage was [ __ ] every [ __ ] in
the world before any like it's crazy
Scotty my brother yeah I can't wait for
him to do a movie or like or a Netflix
series yeah I heard he did a deal with
50. he talked about it too oh Netflix
series I don't know our stars are just
about his life all the hoes he was
[ __ ] all the cocaine his whole story
is crazy it's insane shout out to
storage man uh all right well look your
tape comes out the 16th you said 16th
just incredible presents armeen uh
tapping with your boy yeah go running
around with B real is out right now turn
the music out a lot of music out a lot
of music out already but like a lot of
amazing music on the way like honestly
like I've never been this confident you
know what I'm saying like like when I
just said I've been pressing play on
people like I've never been this
confident to like Press Play in these
meetings so the now song will be on the
album of course yeah that's what I've
been kind of waiting for for an hour
album not only for the album to be done
but honestly I've been kind of figuring
out how to release it that's why I had
all these listening sessions because
you know we talked about this a lot like
I had some meetings with major labels
too but that was never really to move uh
which Distribution Company to go with
even my immediate team not my immediate
day-to-day team but like you know what
I'm saying like the management or
whatever
um so I feel like everything is ready
now you know what I mean boom well we
rather have him rap so you guys could
check out the other YouTube video for
that you let's go all right my man thank
you for having me bro fire